what's going on in mozi nation you're
here with alex from mozy youtube's
richest youtuber uh or richard youtuber
2b um i'm getting for those of you guys
who don't know me my name's alex rosie
we own acquisition.com we do about 85
million a year and you guessed it i've
absolutely nothing to sell you i got a
question the other day that was five
things that millionaires think about uh
that poor people don't and i wanted to
change that to billionaires and that is
because a lot of millionaires have
terrible beliefs and uh you know i tend
to agree with grant cardone on this one
which is uh don't listen to millionaires
listen to a billionaire so you can
choose to listen to me or not i hope
that we will be billionaires in the next
you know 10 to 15 years
but we still have lots of work to go and
hopefully the world doesn't melt down
between now and then all right so these
are the five things that billionaires
think about the millionaires do not
think about number one is the size of
the opportunity a lot of times
millionaires will pursue what most
billionaires would consider small fries
or small chips table stakes things that
are just not that interesting
because there's just not a huge amount
of growth potential now when you're
getting started it's not stupid to niche
down many of the biggest businesses in
the world started with a niche but they
had the ability or possibility to build
something that was going to be truly
enormous and so the total adjustable
market or the potential scale of a
business itself is something that a
billionaire would think about that a
millionaire will not the second thing
that millionaires do not think about or
mistakenly prioritize is they prioritize
promotion over product the biggest
question that a billionaire will ask
about a company is
will people continue to buy this product
over and over and over again and stated
differently
is this something that people will never
stop buying if people will never stop
buying this thing then it will be
inevitable that we will make money right
that is how they were thinking most
millionaires on the other hand just
learned promotion and because that is
how they made their first money because
they didn't make any money and then they
start learning how to promote they make
some money they assume that i should
just do more promotion and with the
exception of very big mass-market brands
that are direct to consumer and have big
ticket items you know for example solar
would be one where you know promotion is
going to matter a lot because you really
are going to only sense sell someone one
time on this for 30 years so promotion's
going to matter more in that situation
but most businesses have a recurring
nature of some sort right and so
making sure that the product is good
enough that when we put the promotion
behind it people do not stop purchasing
it so that we can get outsized returns
on our marketing and our business model
overall is something that billionaires
will think about and not mainers the
third thing that millionaires will will
will mistake here
is they will make the mistake
of thinking i can do this myself or i'll
just underpay just a handful of people
to to to run this with me so they will
have what we call the genius with the
thousands slaves model versus army of
smarter people so the second criteria
that i heard stephen schwartzman who's
the owner of or not owner the founder of
blackstone he's worth about 30 billion
dollars to talk about was that first he
looks at the size of the opportunity and
the second thing that he looks at is
drumroll
can i find 10 out of 10s who want to
pursue this opportunity and so here's
the interesting thing big talent
only chases big opportunity and the
reason and he says this quote it hit me
really hard he said
we didn't say this to exactly but i'm
paraphrasing he said it's harder to
start a small business than it is to
start blackstone because big talent
doesn't want to go pursue a small
business opportunity
think about that for a second that one
totally shook me to my core right is
that the reason we have to have these
big goals is not just for ourselves to
get through the muck of of wanting more
and going and suffering through the
trials and tribulations that come with
entrepreneurship but also so that
everyone around us can stomach it
because they believe in where we are
going and it is something that is true
and it's a vision uh that is compelling
and the opportunity and also the
compensation that they can make right if
you you're running a dry cleaning store
it's very difficult to attract 10 out of
10 talent there and i define 10 edits
and talent as people who are the best in
the world at the thing right nine edits
in talent is the best people in the
world that i can attract given my
company right and eight is somebody who
is very very good at the thing and takes
initiative and can yield outside returns
a seven is someone who is functional but
has to take direction to execute right
in a six and below you don't want them
in your business anyways right and the
vast majority of businesses are run by
sixes and belows let's be real if you're
looking at your team most the team is
probably not best in the world or best
in the world that you can get right of
course not and that is probably because
the size of the opportunity that you're
chasing is not that good number four
is time horizons most millionaires and
people who don't make a lot of money
think in very short time increments they
think in this week and this month
they're thinking can i make payroll can
i make rent and i understand that but
the reason that the people gain outsized
returns who are wealthier is because
they see time as an asset rather than a
liability they see time working for them
rather than against them they see the
opportunity compounding in and of itself
because they have time on their side and
so the smart person the billionaire will
look at the opportunity say does time
help me or hinder me in this opportunity
because i have this little quote that i
like a lot i prefer to play games where
if you wait you win
i'll say it again i prefer to play games
where if you wait you win where success
is an inevitable consequence of time you
may not know when but you do know
whether you will get there i would
rather get rich for sure and get rich
slowly than never get rich at all always
hoping that i'll make it in the next 90
days which is with the vast majority of
millionaires think they're only thinking
about their next promotion they're only
thinking about their next campaign
they're only thinking about the next
thing they're going to do rather than
thinking big picture if i do this for
the next 10 years what is going to
position me for where i want to be and
ultimately the opportunity that i want
to pursue and five the last thing that
billionaires will prioritize over
millionaires is brand and this is
something that i didn't understand
really early on i thought brand was a
waste of money i thought branding was
stupid but a different way of saying
brand is reputation right and i heard a
a man that i that i do business with
frequently say this and i really like
this a lot he said you only get one name
you only get one
and i it really it really struck me
because i just thought that was such a
such a consolidated way of communicating
the point we only get one name and the
thing is is that your brand compounds
with time the more decisions you make
that are integris that are aligned that
are not short-term in thinking that are
not sacrificing your integrity to get
the short dollar which is candidly what
most people do most people do that right
and that's why most people have a so-so
or poor brand right like yeah he's
pretty good but you know he kind of does
some stuff every once in a while it's a
little shady right but if you have an
impeccable brand the other types of
people that you will track will be
people who have impeccable brands and i
can tell you this is that the the area
on the top of the mountain is very very
sparsely populated there are not a lot
of people at the top and they all know
each other it's crazy and you know why
it's because they seek out people who
see the world the same way they see the
world and it's an exception to the rule
rather than the vast majority and so if
you want to have game recognized game if
you want those people to sit across the
table and look at you
as an equal
then it starts with the character of the
person and if the character is right the
billionaire will bet on the character of
the individual knowing that they will
get to where they're trying to go
eventually in enough time because it is
in inevitability provided the values
continue and so when you're making the
business decisions
taking the long route that takes longer
but will most certainly compound and
make you wealthier in the long run
is what billionaires will do rather than
millionaires all right and so i wanted
to make this about billionaires rather
than millionaires because candidly if
you just know how to run some ads you
can be a millionaire right you can learn
how to promote and sell stuff the stuff
you might sell might suck but you might
make enough money to be a billion a
millionaire but to be a billionaire
you got to play the game for a long time
which means you have to understand that
you must play the game for a long time
in order to become a billionaire and if
you're playing the game for a long time
to be a billionaire then all your
decisions are going to be made within
that time horizon in the context that
that that come with that decision-making
process and so if we're thinking about
this if there's one thing
that you can take away from this that
billionaires would think about the
millionaires do not is understanding the
time horizon right because all of these
other components roll into that right
if we have a long time rise and we'll be
doing this forever i don't want to be
the one who's doing it all so i don't
want to be the genius with a thousand
slaves i want an army of smarter people
who are going to do this on my behalf i
want 10 out of 10 who are pursuing this
opportunity and can grow it without me
right if i want this to truly be
something that is going to change my
life i can't pursue a small thing for my
entire life i gotta pursue something big
because it has to be worth it because
and i've heard this from schwartzman and
i love it too he said small goals and
big goals are equally hard so you might
as well make it worth it right it's just
as hard to accomplish making a hundred
thousand dollars a year it is as it is
for somebody to make a billion dollars a
year think about it the time requirement
is the same
arguably it's less to make a billion
dollars a year you have to think
differently about it if i'm going to be
around for a very long time i'm going to
outlive my promotion and so only thing
that will remain will be the product and
what people talk about with the product
and the decisions that i chose to make
with my brand
because i was thinking long term and so
everything comes down to this concept
which is can you think beyond this week
this month this quarter and think when i
look back 80 years from now
are the decisions that i'm making right
now the ones that i would be proud of
that are aligned with the long-term goal
of seizing the big opportunity that is
worth fighting for and so this is what i
have i have learned and gleaned from the
the handful of billionaires that i talk
to and i constantly am trying to analyze
them and think what do they have that i
don't and maybe it's that i'm just too
young and i just need to keep doing what
i'm doing which is oftentimes the
response that i get and so anyways mozy
nation the reason i make this channel is
uh is because there's a lot of broke
people and i don't want to be one of
them these are the traits that
billionaires will will will look through
the lenses of rather than millionaires
who often make short-term short-sighted
mistakes um in pursuing uh their goals
and so i don't want you to do those so
anyways my name is akshamosi like i said
owen acquisition.com i have nothing to
sell you if you like to hit subscribe if
you did and i love you either way and
i'll guys see you guys next video bye